sabíamos que esto no iba a llegar pero
tal vez hasta mañana mañana o tal vez
más nos sentimos bien en el momento en
el que estamos realmente así es
[Música]
estoy aquí para decirles esta noche que
creemos que estamos en camino a ganar
esta elección
[Música]
sabíamos por el voto por correo sin
precedentes que esto va a tomar un
tiempo vamos a tener tener que ser
pacientes hasta que se termine el conteo
de los votos y hasta que cada voto sea
contado
[Música]
pero nos sentimos bien nos sentimos bien
con respecto a dónde estamos creemos que
estamos confiados con respecto a arizona
también nos acaban de dar el estado de
minnesota y seguimos en el juego en
georgia eso no es lo que esperábamos
y nos sentimos muy bien es de wisconsin
y michigan
y de hecho va a tomar tiempo para tomar
para contar los votos y vamos a ganar
pensilvania
estaba hablando con la gente de phil y
de scranton y realmente se sienten
alentados por la cantidad de personas
que ha votado podemos conocer resultados
incluso mayor en la mañana pero tal vez
pueda tomar más tiempo como he dicho
desde el principio no es mi lugar ni el
lugar de donaldson declarar quien ha
ganado esta elección esta es la decisión
del pueblo estadounidense pero yo me
siento optimista con este resultado y
quiero agradecerles a todos a todos los
que salieron y votaron en esta elección
y de hecho chris coons y a los
demócratas
felicitaciones a quien de labor
y yo en el gordo
a todo el equipo han hecho un trabajo
increíble me siento agradecido con todos
los voluntarios con todas las personas
que participaron en este proceso
democrático me siento agradecido con
todas las personas que me apoyaron en
delaware y en toda la nación muchas
gracias muchas gracias y ustedes me han
escuchado decirlo antes cada vez que voy
a esperanto y mi abuela me decía soy
amante en la fe y mi abuela me decía
mantén la fe vamos a ganar esto muchas
gracias vamos a ganar
la paciencia es genial gracias
[Aplausos]